in five four see we just jump right in
three two one
what's up you smelly sexy [ __ ] to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast did I hit record on this video
camera yes I did
just to make damn sure I'm not even sure
if this is lined up whatever it's good
enough today we have a very unspecial
guest there's a living piece of trash
that I've invited into my home mic next
to your face but that might mix your
face you trash bag you could you could
move it it's an articulating arm I
thought you're in production dude yeah
let me tell you something about this
girl so this girl used to work for me
she got fired they sucked because she
sucked at her job and not because she
actually suck it's cuz she got [ __ ]
lazy and that's what pissed me off and
then I got better what a truck Davis Oh
teaches life lessons alright you took
advantage of my kindness alright and I
was gonna kick you in your stomach like
a 300 movie into a pit of death terrible
but today it's gonna be a very special
episode because today's a couple therapy
episode it's a couple therapy episode
but not really because she got cheated
on I don't even think I didn't get
cheated on I think I was the other girl
that's what I'm saying so she got
cheated on yeah misinterpreted
everything so you you're the other girl
I think so you gotta explain the story
from the get-go and I literally didn't
get the details cuz I wanted to have it
on here and I love this part to this
Scott just hide it well first of all how
did you meet horray oh [ __ ] I didn't
even like we won't we won't say names
though I'm just gonna say his name is
Gary I wasn't even supposed to be I
didn't even think I'd be here talking so
well you you explained the story real
quick because I met him on tinder
hey no shame in your game to online
online apps are great yeah online apps
are great
so you met you met Gary Busey I met him
on tinder
he he's a surfer that was my phone
that's okay he I met him like a couple
days before he went on a two-week like
surf trip to Australia and then um he
came back
I did pursue him oh you that aggressive
child huh no maybe no I don't think so
okay is he was interesting enough for me
to pursue and then he was like oh I'm
gonna move there I was like all right
cool
to Australia mm-hmm after formally well
I think for like a holiday visa you
can't really be permanent you have more
steps but he said he's gonna move there
I was like that's cool um super casual
and so we started just hanging out more
and it was a soup it was very casual in
the beginning and then all of a sudden I
started getting serious what did you
want it seriously did he want a serious
though I think over time both of us
wanted it exclusive to one another and
how does that develop because you said
because I remember when you first of all
cuz I remember the fact that she's
dating where it weirds me out I've known
this woman's issue as a child yuck
but uh first of all I was like 19 when
you met me I wasn't a child she was she
she was such a fan too
now she thinks she's so much better than
me she was like I met you and then I can
[ __ ] realize that's like oh it's cool
and so that's you are such trash dude
she always tries to act like she's so
much cooler than me but she was a big
fan and almost and I let her in my life
it's just like a fan of yes and then
everybody else they go oh he's actually
not that great and they just move on so
you guys so if you decided that you
originally wanted it to be casual what
made you want to make it serious though
that's the part that always messes me up
and
we were hanging out a lot more and then
we just started developing feeling
suddenly like what about because he was
what got Amala because you found
yourself a Guatemalan surfer boy now
he's very um what the Milan you complete
opposite of me very open to like trying
new things like on an extreme level as
well
what just anything he was open to
anything
I'm normally not that open yeah I think
it was just very opposites attract he
wasn't he's not online at all like oh
he's like one of those [ __ ] huh I don't
believe in being online because it takes
away from the source of life itself
no I think he just didn't understand
that so he was stupid okay okay what is
Ines de Grimes what's why is every bone
ice - Grimes
so he's she's fine that everybody hangs
on r.i.p alright people but not really
so i think he was really opposites
attract type situation and i'm
definitely different than all the other
girls so he probably was hanging out
with before because i'm very low-key
type a and then so like it got to the
point where he liked him at my grandpa
and stuff like that's what you [ __ ] up
that's what you [ __ ] up how dare you
invite him to hide money and how do i
geez place he no I it was like a very I
didn't think much of it it was like I
was saying oh I'm gonna go visit my
grandpa on the weekend here's oh can I
come with you okay sure that's a big
step though yeah and I didn't for a
booty call you brought a baby call to
see the holy grandparents I mean I
didn't they must have had a heart attack
when they found out that he was gonna
mom they're like why is it a Mexican
person here my grandma in Korean
literally when he met him he said to him
he was like he has a good face and I was
like okay cool but he's a dirty dirty
Guatemalan I'm only saying that just
because you know I'm pretty sure your
cream grandparents wanted you to bring
the Korean boy home oh of course I don't
think my grandpa it was more my grandma
I wanted that but he didn't meet my
grandma thank God
yeah so that happened and then we just
you know started it was pretty much a
relationship yeah until he left and then
I frickin well right before he left he
was drunk gave me his phone and there
was this girl messaging him well I was
like taking care of his ass like
throwing up in my bathroom
oh you choose great men by the way
that's not as a fent that's a sign of a
fantastic man listen I can't argue so it
was like this girl like what's up em and
it was just like saying hey babe like so
and so me like almost like a
conversation that's continuous of
someone that you're dating long-distance
you're telling them about your day right
yeah and then she called the phone
I didn't pick up because I'm also like
this is not my phone I didn't pick it up
but then right after it was a missed
call she messaged again she was like oh
I just called to like say quick hello
and I was like okay this is something
I'm gonna bring up tomorrow when he's
[ __ ] sober
mmm-hmm so I brought it up and then we
got into an archive an argument as well
because when we in the beginning when I
was starting to get like a little more
exclusive like we told each other we
weren't gonna be on all those like
dating app dating apps and all of that
so I was like okay that's fine like for
me it's like it's easy like I'm not one
of those people that's a ho know like I
like my options open I'm open like I
don't I just like alright this person I
like so I'll continue whatever it is and
then so not only did I see her messages
I saw so-and-so on tinder new message or
some [ __ ] like that and I was like
thinking I was like okay this is like
exactly the opposite of what we had
discussed and up was supposed to be or
whatever yeah so we I didn't bring up
the girl the whatsapp messages until
later but my first thing I brought
when we the next day I was like you told
me you weren't gonna be on tinder and
then so we got into this longer argument
impressive within an argument what was
his defense because it that's the thing
I should have liked already like kind of
because I'm trying to figure out how can
an argument develop from that because
there's no defense I understand an
argument when there's like clearly
there's some but there's like a
misinformation ya know so he made it
seem like it was a misinformation saying
like I'm not on it like or like I don't
even know come on guy
you are the worst liar on earth
literally told him I was like do you
think I'm stupid like you wouldn't be
getting these notifications if you
didn't have the app on your phone yeah
so like it's one of those things were
like for like a week we didn't see each
other so he's literally the worst liar
on earth so his tinder thing popped up
he goes dude I don't know what that is
pretty much he acted stupid even read oh
yeah I replied to your tinder Commons
just bite love okay I just interpreted
the love and I talked back I'm go
surfing for a second okay you chose
literally the worst human being on earth
I okay yeah I don't know I a lot of red
flags came up and I chose to ignore it
um and I was very conscious of that I
don't know why per say I kind of already
knew I felt like that I was gonna get
hurt which is really I've got some
issues that I need to work out probably
okay so you already had a bad feeling
about him he saw the tender stuff and
then you actually saw the message from
his real girlfriend which at the time
you couldn't really say yeah because I
didn't like it wasn't like so like it
wasn't like a nude or anything like that
like I can't assume that it was just hey
I wanted the job I thought it was a it
could be a friend like well Who am I to
like whatever so I brought up the tinder
thing and then he did that whole like oh
I'm not I know I don't know you know I'm
not on the app get how this I don't know
how this telefono works all right I
don't get it right I'm I'm going to
Mahlon okay I'm like so Guatemalan you
can't even believe how Claude Amol and I
am right
I think I think one of the things I
should have really like decided like
this is it was he was getting his dick
sucked in your living room
that's probably ya know he I asked him I
was like do you still want to see each
other like cuz I was like first of all
do you think I'm stupid like I was like
you don't get these messages if you
don't have that out like that's yeah of
course cuz if he if you guys were meant
to be exclusive than he should have just
removed the app right like you said he
would which he's the one who I never
even asked him about that if he's the
hazard or not he has he had continually
like continuously said like oh I got rid
of it and like I'm well that's just
already a sign that somebody's lying
yeah you know you know what I mean it's
like so so for example like there's this
dude in high school he would
consistently mention things that he has
that nobody asked him that he has do you
understand what I'm saying so it would
be on something like this so for example
he got this you know we're we're all
broke kids but at the time he it's when
Sion just came out and he got a scion tc
so him already having a scion tc was
dope as [ __ ] we're all broke kids
everybody had used cars and [ __ ] like
that but he had a brand new Scion tC and
this guy was known to be a habitual liar
but it would be on some [ __ ] like oh
dope car he goes yeah I got a turbo on
it like what like nobody you know what
I'm saying like he would volunteer these
things and it was so weird because why
would you put out this misinformation
because it when it wrists when it gives
you a higher risk of being called out
for [ __ ] and it was just so random yeah
I just put a new turbo in it but one of
our friends his news name was her name
still friends to this day
yeah you remember Renee right Renee was
the loud ass [ __ ]
that's scared of them yeah so Renee
Renee's not a punk and also on top of
that Renee is somebody who's highly
opinionated and he's not afraid to call
people out on their [ __ ] even he's worse
than I am
and so he's just like okay cool man
we're gonna go to your house after check
it out he goes ah but it's not in yet ok
well let us know when it comes in right
so he would hit him up a week later he
goes yo did you put that turbo in yet he
does all something happen and shipping
I'm saying and so he would repeatedly
just tell us about the turbo in his car
for some reason he thought it would
solidify the fact that it was true if he
keeps mentioning it and that's what guys
like that do so like I understand if
it's like a story that has to do with
something within that conversation yeah
but when it comes out of the blue and
has nothing to do with anything it's
kind of odd it's kind of a tell right
maybe if it's like maybe if it's like a
conversation like this we're just trying
to be entertaining so we have all these
stories that we want to tell that it
makes sense but if it's among like
somebody you're comfortable with yeah
and especially a couple person like for
example here's a big example right
there's dudes out there till this day
that are so [ __ ] dumped if they
actually think that this works on their
girlfriend so they'll meet a girl
they're going out for a few months
out of nowhere they're watching TV but
chillin on the couch there they're
watching a movie little titty comes out
they go babe I don't know why guys watch
porn I don't know I don't even what I
don't get it I don't get white guys
watch porn like porn is disgusting you
probably watch the most sickest [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've ever heard of in my life
you probably watch a donkey [ __ ] a
[ __ ] I'm sorry that's not right a
little person is that the correct
politically correct term that's PC okay
well you probably watched a donkey
[ __ ] a tiny person a little son of a
[ __ ] and then having sex with the
unicorn [ __ ] an old lady and that's
normal to you the unicorn just a regular
horse with the horn on it no it's an
actual [ __ ] unicorn and that's some
real [ __ ] people who do like I'm telling
you every dude like I keep saying they
should they I don't I've never watched
porn that's a lie that is a I've seen
porn
everybody has seen porn I used to watch
porn frequently consistently it was
almost hard for me not to watch porn now
I watched so much porn she just saw I
don't want to see it anything that's
called an addiction no because I stopped
whenever I wanted to and I and I and I
rarely ever watch porn now just because
it's not as fun as it used to be I think
you kind of you see everything you just
kind of desensitize yeah maybe it's just
because it's just everything's out there
so it's not as entertaining but HIV
shows
I heard Game of Thrones got mad titties
dude the first season first second
episode a third rape straight I was
talking about sex you were straight away
you sick [ __ ] I'm extreme you sick [ __ ]
anyways so he's giving you these tales
about I I mean I knew something was up
but I chose to ignore it because maybe
it was one of those things raised like
he's gonna leave in a couple weeks so
why like I just want to end it on a
better note because we weren't gonna
talk like be together or like have a
relationship after he left because first
off the whole of the continent and I
didn't already trust him in that sense
too because but you decide to get into a
serious relationship with this person
and you're not making any sense right
now but I don't know how this even like
I don't because my logical brain this
normally would not happen cuz how I
pictured it was so I met this dude on
tinder well we had to go meet up at
lunch he was shooting up cocaine and I
said to myself I'm gonna fight this man
to see my grandparents okay and then so
like he left for Australia because no we
were like okay well so I'll see each
other like and I wanted to end it on a
good note or like a like a whatever blow
jobs gotcha anyways he leaves and then
the day after my [ __ ] grandma passes
away and my grandparents are very like
I'm very close to them so that [ __ ] hit
the fan literally a day after he left
rest in peace grandma and then two weeks
later while I started working a new gig
like that like that girl kept coming oh
also when I brought up the tinder thing
after I brought up oh who is so-and-so I
saw your phone like when you gave it to
me and she tried to call you and then
his argument or not argument his defense
I don't even know what a phone is man
what's the phone he said that she was a
good friend and then when we got on the
phone to talk about that situation he
was like I even know her
Bend and I was like okay see there you
go do you see that it's that random
extra piece of information that has
nothing to do with what's being said
yeah you know it's like dude who's that
girl I know her husband yeah that's not
what I asked you what are you what are
you saying right now I was like okay
[ __ ] do I do that I want him to check
myself continue you better be careful
I know you do that [ __ ] but so I was
like okay fine I'm gonna whatever and
that's when you know he laughed and then
everything happened my grandma and then
two weeks later I started a brand new
gig but that conversation kept popping
in my head like it was like what is that
message yeah who is this girl and it
started with the seed of him lying about
the tinder thing too so he already he's
already in a bad position and that just
makes you doubt the other thing now hmm
so this is where girls can really I
don't even think it's girls anyone who
knows the Internet you can really find
anyone mind you he doesn't have an
Instagram he doesn't have a Facebook he
only has a Spotify this is where it's
gonna make it look like I'm crazy no I
don't think so because he's lied a
couple times already so it's like what
are you gonna do at this point this is
true
I mean maybe or maybe not get with
somebody like that but continue that's
future
so he's so music was pretty music is was
like one of the things that we really
connected on very different taste but
you know whatever
he followed himself via my Spotify
because that's the only social media he
has of course and then so I have my you
know you have your desktop open you have
you can see on your Spotify desktop your
friends that you follow what they're
playing mm-hmm I saw his name and I was
like okay I'm gonna go onto his Spotify
went to his Spotify
I went to his followers found her found
her on Facebook
then I found you you're not crazy at all
this dog then found her Instagram mhm
and then the first story that I saw on
her thing was a picture of him with her
cat and it says my two loves Oh
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] spiraled and it was like
10:00 p.m. and I was working late it was
my first day there's not a grandma
passed away yeah
so you need yeah it was a lot of weird
emotions happening I think in my head
very sensitive to things at that point
and I that was my first day of my new
gig and then I coincidentally that day
we were working late and as soon as I
saw that on Instagram luckily it was
like Tempe and my boss was like oh you
can go home now
and I was like cool and I [ __ ] called
my best friend I'm like I'm coming over
so you got your Glock you put you I got
you go ahead no I was like an emotional
wreck and you know me I don't cry I
don't like I'm not emotional really so
like I get to my friends my best
friend's house and I'm like crying and
she's like what the [ __ ] cuz I've always
been the person that is very logical and
kind of an [ __ ] and doesn't like not
in that sense like vulnerable mm-hmm
so then I was like I don't know what to
do do I like at this point for me is
like I'm pissed off at him but like I
have nothing to say to him anymore and
it's more like do I say something to her
but like it's been now like a couple
weeks since I found out and I ultimately
I decided not to reach out to her
because I would have burned reality down
I've been like hey guess what I'm the
side [ __ ] and I've been sucking your
man's dick because you don't do it for
him I've been sucking and dry like a
mummy I would I would burn that visual
in her [ __ ] brain you know all those
times that you took pictures of that cat
in him he was and you were like my two
loves guess what I was the other love
that you didn't know about oh here's all
my spit has been in your mouth because
you've been sucking his yeah okay first
of all she's in Australia they're in
Australia together all right matey
here's also another thing they're really
like like triggered me is that so when
he first came back again yeah it's the
whole information I didn't ask for is
that he had a ring on this like the left
hand yeah and then I didn't ask him
about him we were just hanging out he's
like oh look at this new like ring that
I got like this lady in Australia gave
it to me she got from India and I was
okay cool like he keeps he keeps doing
it
so he's like trying to nip something in
the bud before it happens but there's no
reason to do it yeah
like you'll have he'll just have like
for example like a red mark maybe on his
neck that looks like a scratch and he'll
just come in a man that crate it was a
crazy sword fight earlier you know when
you [ __ ] yeah you know when you just go
into a medieval town and people just
start throwing spears at your neck that
looks like a like a like a like a like a
like a like a like a like a like a
little lip you know say like god I'm not
I'm not making out with anybody well
that's what say this guy so [ __ ]
weird so yeah so I never asked about
that right and then he got a gift from
me there was a ring that I had that I
got when I was really young but I don't
I don't wear it it wasn't like a thing
but it's like there's elephant hair in
it and I just got out of a gift from a
family member and so he has that of mine
so he wears it on this hand right that
photo that I saw at Instagram I still
see he wears that ring so my thing is he
has her ring here he has my ring here
and I'm like I was like [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] psychopath did I date for like
three four months I was like what the
[ __ ] that's so weird
that's so [ __ ] and weird you know
when he came back from Australia like I
didn't because it was so cat-like right
the first time we saw each other after
he came back like I was just asking
about oh did you like meet any girls out
there like I heard Australian people are
like whatever right like it was me also
sussing out I think like if this is just
gonna be like I'll call you once in a
while till you leave but then he was
like oh no like I've only been surfing
and then the next surfing and [ __ ]
obviously and then like when we saw each
other right after that he like he was
again I know you're gonna see this I
need better people
he was really drunk your choice and man
like I don't as this story unfolds I
hate that guy but I also hate you too
trust me I know after he kicked the
child over he's critical and was drunk
he was like asking me if I had hooked up
with anyone while he was gone
like he I think wanted to see that as
well and I didn't and he seems like the
guy that even though he's cheating on
you he would have got mad they saw
somebody else yeah it's like how [ __ ]
dare you
yeah I realized later on but anyways
yeah when I saw that photo I saw the
photo of him like he was holding a cat
and it was on the other side I saw him
wearing my ring and I was like Allah so
how come you decided not to tell her
what was the reason I mean the only
reason why is you know I joke about
saying like for revenge purposes right
which is a joke but not really a joke
but at the same time I also think for me
I'll be like man maybe that girl should
know it's one of those things or it's
like he could manipulate the situation
we're not in the same city I don't think
he can manipulate the situation because
he is considered one of the worst liars
on earth like she might be as stupid and
as like [ __ ] like oh who the [ __ ]
cares it would it would still stir some
[ __ ] up it would get her thing good
plantus just because for you to in your
in your tender situation it planted a
seed enough for you to find the truth
yeah right and it kind of sucks that you
had to go through this route where it
made you seem like a crazy person but it
only valid if I'd you're it only
validated your doubt so that's where
it's really [ __ ] with my head too
because I already have trust issues and
vulnerability issues because of how I
was raised
yeah so that's why I didn't you've never
seen me really date either because I
chose to not like be vulnerable with
people on that level I don't like to put
myself out there on that term because I
don't trust people on that and then the
one time I actually yeah but let me just
bring this back to you for a second I do
believe in personal responsibility no if
you don't have if you have trust issues
right and you have trusting people you
sure as [ __ ] chose the best specimen for
your first time then what the [ __ ] I
think part of it and I thought about
this a lot part of it was probably like
hey this isn't really your real
relationship commitment for me because
he's gonna leave oh you know what I mean
like it wasn't serious till after he had
already decided to leave and we had
started spending more time together
so he's so weird like his lying habits
are so bad it's so [ __ ] bad how bad
his lies are it's like he comes in right
and he just smells like [ __ ] and he'll
come in he goes dude you know these new
clothes you smell like fresh [ __ ]
isn't that crazy babe like what was
awkward is your [ __ ] perfume squirt
squirt squirt like what's wrong with
this guy his lies are so [ __ ] odd I
don't get him yeah it's it's it's sitcom
lies isn't a sitcom I was an idiot and I
admit I chose to ignore these things
like was he that cute I thought he was
killed yeah Oh sick disgusting
Taysom it's fantastic and don't change
the subject to my feet you know what's
disgusting your habits in men anyways
this is Joe but um yeah I don't I feel
like if there was a conversation it's
between him and me I do unfortunately
believe that it's habitual so he's gonna
do it again out there well I guess like
for me I'm just saying well isn't it's
definitely not your responsibility and
you don't have to do it yeah but I'm not
worried about his [ __ ] ass I'm worried
about the girl now I'm like okay well if
this happened to me and this is what I'm
going through maybe I should let her
know so she doesn't have to go through
the [ __ ] but you know all your skeletons
in your closet
ventually get revealed yeah so it's
going to happen I'm just kind of like
damn that girl's and she's probably just
like you he's over here with that
elephant hair ring and sigkill where did
you get that ring oh you know sometimes
when you you know I hunted an elephant
when I was 13 and then I took the butt
hair holes out of the elephant and I
made a ring out of it because you know
what life's full of [ __ ] and sometimes
you got to rip out dingleberries out of
an elephant oh I knew what you would say
that's so sweet that story that's what
she would say that's what you would say
to your story so real first of all I've
never said that
oh my god how did you get the elephant
butthole hair I heard the tensile
strength is really strong how did you
cut it
like [ __ ] like [ __ ] like barbecue
wire that's crazy
so what the hell so what's going on
right now did you did you did you uh did
you guys officially call it off or did
you let him know I back on a kangaroo
back to Australia no we called it off
when he when I dropped him off at the
airport what did you say to him
you cheated on me you're a piece of
trash and no no because I didn't find
out till after he was gone that's what
I'm saying is that I did not find this
out till after he just gets to live his
life and you're over here trying to be a
little [ __ ] Buddha well you know
that's so uncaring of you
Korean people all about revenge I would
make him pay I would find an old used
condom Oh Korean like how Korean am I to
you
you got the most kookiest face I've ever
seen in my life Marie's in Orange County
that's why you wanted to get that
Guatemalan surfer boy you couldn't just
find yourself a nice regular white boy
no because they're boring oh really how
[ __ ] dare you
white people are the bread to America
the staple of America I'll have you know
Wonder Bread you're right I'll have you
know [ __ ] white people man they when
they wake up in the morning they put
their pants on two legs at a time all
right
[ __ ] white people are [ __ ] white you
know I'm saying they're fun they're fun
they wake up and they make eggs and
oatmeal oh and they eat it and they eat
that [ __ ] that's how great they are
oh so after you after this all happened
you found everything out huh
you chose not to say anything I mean I
still like I'm still I chose right now
but I came to my mind every second but I
don't think I should change it right now
get your [ __ ] phone and you message
me I have a drafted email send that [ __ ]
out right now bring out your phone right
now send that [ __ ] out right now send it
out right now I'm not making decisions
and it said send it out right come on he
played you I know he did he played the
[ __ ] out of you oh and by the way I just
found out he's a part of the KKK
so this this is yeah
you have a civil duty to take this
racist down he is a self-hating
Guatemalan he thinks he's white well he
probably does think he's white he's a
surfer you know what he does when he
serves he kills sharks and dolphins did
you know that and you're not I sent this
email out
you said you send this [ __ ] email out
right now no well how are you coping
with being cheated on then
are you gonna are you going to take this
negative experience and just continue
not to trust people no I think I'm
trying to you cuz it's still fresh I'm
still trying to figure out how I'm like
coping with everything stupid Gary I
realized um that partying doesn't help
me um at all like I just don't feel good
after it I could have told you that
years ago but you loved it you little
stupid Instagram stories girls are so
[ __ ] funny cuz girls are the only
people that could just insult their
friends on on insta story like it's a
compliment out with this come Gus
it's like your best forehead click out
what this [ __ ] gaping hole vagina
[ __ ] pack and what girls do you you
this is your insta story I've never
caught any of my friend well you've had
versions of that [ __ ] it's always you
out there in the [ __ ] bar with a
piece I'd cover your [ __ ] face I hate
that [ __ ] so looking like the Phantom of
the Opera and [ __ ] how [ __ ] dare you
anyways
what was I saying Oh
partying doesn't help okay what else did
you order I started working out a lot
more again and then like just redoing
like just doing productive things like
redoing my room or like I built a
[ __ ] cleaner car yes oh really I did
but it's dirty again cuz I'm in
production right now a bunch of sure
look at your car looks
like you told a crackhead that's been
off like crack for two days to find a
crack rock inside your car that's what
your car looks like and then he
defecated inside of it and blew it up
that's what your car looks like that's
that's only when I'm like busy working
no that's that's not my car to like
often is I was busy working for you and
you know Dan okay so yeah and as we
mentioned before you were fired because
you barely worked so how much were you
really working because after when we did
[ __ ] I was [ __ ] burned out I don't
give a [ __ ] if you were burnt out guess
who was more burnt out me [ __ ] and you
were supposed to help me out the trash
bag first on his phone he has me as
poodle [ __ ] poodle oh he hasn't changed
that in like five six years
I'll tell you this too right now poor
choices I want a new name on your phone
it terrible so your grandma passed away
yes
look at that smooth transition yeah pull
it away from me just so sad um yeah but
it's one of those things or it's like it
wasn't like she was young and it was it
she lived a very full life she had kids
she had grandkids she's seen her oldest
grandkid get married like it's like
maybe it's because I'm callous to death
unfortunately with my family history she
was but it was like the funeral like it
was like full circle type of feeling
like did you cry a lot during the
funeral not too much what yeah only when
my younger cousin did the eulogy the
youngest cousin her level of crying from
one to ten um during the funeral yeah
maybe a five a five you heartless sack
of [ __ ] it was your grandma it was my
grandma but I let me tell you something
dude my grandma beat me like everybody
she beat me like I owed her money and I
kid you not she once told my mom to get
a to get a paternity
you test to see if I was easier to part
of the family how do I you would have
thought that woman was a professional
Muay Thai fighter the way she beat me oh
my grandma never beat me she left me and
you gave her a five cry yeah I know she
wouldn't want me to cry everybody says
that your grandma was Korean
she was when she passed away she's like
these people better [ __ ] me I better
see tears and she saw your five crises I
you don't you know my aunt said maybe
maybe this is just justifying my own
head she said that I forgot who said it
to her or it was like a Korean saying
but people who cry a lot during a
funeral it's because they have a lot of
regret towards the person who passed
away and stuff that they wish that they
did I mean I think that's partially true
but the other half of that is just
complete [ __ ] because I also believe
people cry at funerals because you're
miss your you're thinking about all the
great times that you're gonna miss this
person's gonna miss in your life and
that you want them to be a part of it so
for example let's say for example let's
say my my mom passed right now I'll put
it right now I'm a dope-ass son maybe
not when I was younger but my mom and I
are like best friends I'm not gonna
think about all the bad things I've I've
had with her absolutely not I'm gonna
think about when I have kids they're not
gonna they're not gonna ever get to meet
how amazing my mom is they're not gonna
be able to eat her food I'm not gonna be
able to eat her food I'm not gonna be
able to talk to remember these are the
types of things I think about I think
I've already thought about that with my
mom's passing yeah this was more of a
like she was like a second mom to me but
it was almost like only a five cry worth
though she was tired you know she was
more relief yeah it was 80s she was 87
and from like two or three years ago she
was like I just wanted go she was like
I'm tired your parents always do that
she did they're like it's time yeah
they're 65 because I kept let me go but
they still live to like a thousand years
old ugly
and like my grandparents as well they
had to prep this long ago like 20 years
ago they bought like their plot of land
Forest Lawn and like all their casket
liked it
I ain't paying that dope-ass places yeah
they paid for everything so that we
wouldn't have to worry it like my aunt's
wouldn't have to worry about it or
anything when it did happen like making
those decisions too little tougher
during those times but it's like she had
for the past couple years been like her
health declining and it was one of those
things where it's like she was like I'm
tired she was like sounds like a hoot
she was she was my my dad deals with a
lot of people like me because he owns a
business but you know he said it best
and he was like I've never met anyone as
kind as your grandma like she she was
the martyr of the family and she was
very much the glue to everything well
like I love my grandpa he's a street of
[ __ ] like you know a lot of a lot of
Asian grandparents they seem to be the
hardened ones though and the grandmas
usually had like the really soft part I
mean I told you this earlier but like
one of my aunts was visiting and who he
doesn't have a good relationship with
visiting at the nursing home he's
already know he and this is him telling
me the story and he was very proud of it
and he was like I told her why are you
here I'm not dead yet oh yeah that's the
thing
like I loved him my relationship with
him is great but he's a big ol [ __ ]
I'll tell you this right now if there is
a heaven you might have a little trouble
just a little trouble getting in I think
he he knows he's an [ __ ] too and I
was like you need to be nicer please be
nice during this like when the whole
funeral thing was happening like I had
to like sidebar with my own grandfather
and said can you make sure it'd be nice
please like you know what's so
interesting too is so funny how the
[ __ ] gets to live longer than a nice
person and my mom put it like this
because we have a family friend who went
through the same situation where the
Albia the grandfather looked a lot worse
than the grandmother and he looked like
he was gonna pass away but the
grandmother passed away first and the
grandpa lived and how my mom put it was
honestly she felt that it was because
the grandma was such a loving person she
put all of her energy and taking care of
this guy and it took away from her and
so he basically sucked the spirit out of
this
I've heard this thing too like Koreans
say that I'm like my grandpa we all
thought that he was gonna be the first
one to pass because the past two years
he was in and out of the hospital
because he has a congestive heart
failure so his heart only functions like
30 or something percent that's it and so
he like it doesn't flow enough heat gets
he's like a Great Dane a little bit yeah
he got like fluid that's always in his
lungs that they have to take out if it
gets too much as his breathing gets bad
so we were all getting ready for him to
pass and then all of a sudden my grandma
was very sudden she was taking a nap and
then BOOM yeah and just they found out
she had she had the flu and then it was
like one of those things were at their
age and when they get the flu it's done
yeah because it's their bodies can only
take so much but yeah when they're 100
years old like I said flu is like
literally getting the bubonic plague
pretty much for them at their age and
like so it's one like she we all thought
to you
maybe my family's a little bit more
morbid than normal but we thought that
she would pass in her sleep so we're
glad at least it was painless and she
was taking a nap midday I was like I was
gonna die I'm gonna die in front of
everybody dude I want this to be
dramatic I know when I die I want to be
like super old and I want to do the
whole I want to put like literally 30
rows of pills and just slide them all
off the table super dramatic and they
start knocking all these [ __ ] little
yeah start dropping all my pills just so
everybody knows I died yours big dude
they can't miss that oh no they're gonna
I'm gonna make sure everybody sees it
and then when I fall I'm also gonna
attach little matches on my wrist and
it's gonna strike and a light fireworks
so you're really planning your death at
this percent I actually had a
conversation with Meryl yesterday where
I told her hey by the way you cannot die
before me I have to die before you oh
yes I can and I did I told her straight
up you have to die before me because I
genuinely believe if I died before her
she'll be fine but if she died before me
I'm [ __ ] oh yeah I'm [ __ ]
oh yeah I'm
totally [ __ ] I wouldn't know what to
do like if she leaves me I'm even told
her this very moment if she [ __ ]
leaves me I'm [ __ ] you're single for
life I'm single for life you'll maybe
have a dog maybe if I have enough if my
heart and cemented heart has enough room
for a dog but you'll have roommates for
life you love people
I'll have roommates forever I'm just
gonna be that creepy all do they still
thinks he's young and [ __ ] yeah like 20
year old does your with me where's the
party at kids let's pop in that's gonna
be [ __ ] me why'd you turn into a
suburban dad because that's exactly who
I am dude gross you need to make better
life choices but I do what is it I don't
understand like what attracted you to
the guy aside from the fact that you
said that
oh he's different or something else do
you think it was a very superficial
probably it was too too short and cute
like lack of better term intense for me
to really like if it was a long fashion
he came in little Gustavo he came in and
he was like hello Daniel I haven't seen
you in years
and at least I can see you and here's
you drop your clothes your weird puffy
jacket with holes on the armpits it's
stupid and then you're like oh my god
Gustavo how did you get this horse
inside my house and like I find
different ways your little kinky face
cookie girl well I want you to give me a
[ __ ] with chopsticks
that sounds not and that's what you
meant by the passion was too old too
crazy huh I think it was too short for
me to really decipher why I was
attracted to him was he can and all buff
and [ __ ] no he was not tan and all buff
what was he he's kind of tan but not
really but he was going buff he was a
surfer it's not a bodybuilder okay I'm
just saying I'm trying to figure out
what the cut with the hot connection is
cuz you've liked boys before so I don't
understand I think so I've heard in a
fable somewhere that you've liked boys
before so I'm trying to figure out maybe
what the connection was that made you so
hot for this one compared to no but I
think it comes down to again like I knew
he was leaving so I wasn't really to me
it was like
just go with it so you caught feelings
for a guy that you knew was leaving yeah
so the you didn't you didn't really
think about what would happen after he
left no I thought and you decided to
make it exclusive even you knew if you
really know you understand what I'm
trying to I want you to think this
through right now because you're telling
me this story actually I actually like
Jeffrey a lot more all right I didn't
think much of it were you caught off
guard when you cried about him yeah I
was like what the [ __ ] like I actually
like him more than I yeah it was like I
was like it felt like a train hit me and
I didn't first time you've ever felt
that dude that was your first heartbreak
yeah congratulations
that [ __ ] sucks I know
if you have never had your heart broken
ever first of all I I can try to
remember what it feels like and I've
only had my heart broken once in my life
by a girl and I've never had my heart
broken after that but as an 18 year old
kid that gets dumped by a girl that you
think that or was it 19 but I was a
teenager that gets dumped by a girl who
you have wrapped your whole life around
and even if even your case who you
didn't do that but that's what in the
moment that's what it feels like to have
that [ __ ] shattered was probably one of
the worst feelings I've ever felt in my
life I I've seen relationships from my
family to my friends and all that so I I
made it a life goal to avoid that you
can't avoid that [ __ ] I know I realized
that at the age of 27 it's it's pretty
[ __ ] terrible dude like I remember
describing it only because I used to
write music and I used to be my feelings
I remember describe it felt like my
heart just sank into the middle of my
stomach
yeah and it just felt like it was
boiling in a bucket of Tears that's what
it feels like yeah it literally feels
like your heart is ripped and it falls
into your gut yeah and I just remember I
just I can't exactly remember the the
physical feeling that I had from it but
I just remembered that's how I described
it it was so terrible I physically like
I had
no appetite I barely ate I couldn't
sleep for like a week and like it was
just one of those things I was like I
was trying to decipher this feeling
because I'm I'm such a like like logical
person or like practical for the most
part and I'm like this doesn't make
sense to me I shouldn't feel this way
because of what he did I'm not emotional
I just starved myself I went to a
Wendy's I got myself a bunch of
cheeseburgers and I cried it to my
burger as I ate it in an empty parking
lot with my best raining it was not
raining but it might as well have from
the tears and the river that I created
in the middle that parking lot from my
Pig don't you [ __ ] laugh you
understand me don't you [ __ ] don't
jump how [ __ ] dare you alright I
cried into my burger and it got soggy
from the tears and I remember because of
the sound I made when that bread muffled
might my my cries don't you [ __ ]
laugh this is a very serious moment and
I was eating this [ __ ] burger and the
Wendy's chili and my best friend he
can't even look at me cuz I look like a
little plus and he's just no but at
least you you dealt with that earlier on
I'm like here now I'm like I'm why this
is like why would anyone want to be in a
relationship if this is your first
serious relationship ever
exclusively oh so you just slang in that
puss around huh plus Alaia it's not like
you want to know that okay first of all
I wasn't sure but I I would have people
that like I hooked up with and it was
very casual yeah and then so it wasn't
like you know you just couldn't get
emotionally how can you get your
feelings hurt when you're not even yeah
I wasn't I wasn't to the point where I
wanted to be emotionally attached to
anyone and then not only that cuz like I
quit college to have a career so that
was always my main that's such an
interesting state sentence that's what I
did it's just hearing you say it sounds
so funny that's something I said - I'm
like
daaamn David are you saying that a
college shows like quit college
everybody you're wasting your life like
I'm Gary Vee I'm Gary Vee without money
who is he though like I've heard like
he's like Jillian there you look I'm not
gonna even tell you who Gary B is just
look just look him up remember he was on
hot ones and I was like who this dude
look him up and you'll know what's up
okay he has the pedigree to talk like
the way he does the problem is I talk
like Gary Vee but I'm broke so don't
ever listen to what I say
welcome to genius my podcast well I
think when half younger it's because
when I dropped out of college I told my
dad I was like hey I'm not gonna go to
school anymore because I started getting
production stuff all evasion well you
know what I wasn't learning stuff in
school like it was I was going for film
anyways you know I really need a phone
degree and like right now looking at
like all the kids that I started college
with they're not like half of them
aren't even in them how dare you talk
about formula arts thing huh
how [ __ ] dare you talk about formula
I would like to also point out that one
of the first things that Khalif acted I
guess in the website I actually met
Cleef through her yeah but how dare you
talk about Tom e-tron's formula arts
that he did all by himself
I mean farts formula farts how [ __ ]
dare you
Oh a person so this formula arts by the
way was a little film group that she was
a part of that actually worked with JK
films in the beginning and then Daniel
Quan you know the guy who did my
sketches actually was a part of formula
arts and then he did a lot of my
sketches which I miss him and I [ __ ]
up because that [ __ ] messaged me the
other day he was like wondering when are
we gonna when are you gonna get me food
and I was like excuse me you're busy did
I miss that do so much I tell you this
right now I'm so stupid because I keep
pushing people into the medical field he
went he went to [ __ ] he told Vanessa
to Vanessa's in chiropractics I'm a
dream curator but in that process I have
to let my
dream diamond well I got fired and I'm
still in the industry yeah you learned a
good life lesson they raised a little
[ __ ] okay I have to lecture you like
you're my little child yeah you're a
grown-ass woman and did I just fire
people left and right dude that's like
my [ __ ] yeah you know why's cuz I
believe in talent but sometimes the work
ethic doesn't match the talent and
sometimes you have to get burned to know
not to touch the hot stove I'm saying
things right now yeah you're just
viewing [ __ ] that's right but so when I
quit college my dad simply said to me it
was like if you're gonna quit that's
fine obviously I can't come into
otherwise he's like but if you're gonna
do it you better do what you're doing
well he's like do good like excel in it
and be the best if not like this is
gonna be a waste for you yeah
so and I also grew up with the my
parents drilled in my head maybe it's
because I was around like really strong
females and my family is on my mom side
my dad sides in Korea my mom said it's
all sisters she had five sisters so it's
all they also all have the pants in
their relationship so they're very
strong-headed and like females my uncles
are gonna hear this and there would be
so mad they're like how [ __ ] dare you
I'm gonna tell on you to my wife right
now and then my parents since I was
young said don't have a boyfriend till
you're 30 and I would like I thought he
was like the funny like oh you're not
gonna have a boyfriend type protectively
and I like one day I asked him out why
they're like we want you to have a
career that you can like be
self-sufficient and not rely on a guy
and you chose film awesome exactly and
then they were like you know if you're
going to if you end up in relationship
to early in your age especially as a
girl you're gonna end up relying on that
that was their mentality so they're like
we really don't want you to be in any
relationship till you're in your 30s
because you're gonna get rekt that's
literally what they said and they're
like we'd want you to have a career be
self-sufficient enough and then but you
could have a career and then be with
somebody along the way you could but you
know Korean parents are extreme yeah see
the one or the other yeah it's either
you get married
super-early have kids super early or you
just [ __ ] focus on work yeah so that
was enough for me to be busy in my head
when I was younger
Gustavo Gustavo Heyman is stupid
Guatemalan horse that only eats celery
and maybe some carrots on the side tell
are you disgusting you know what I
actually don't my salary as much helps
me poop isn't there other things that
you can eat that helps you poop yeah
laxatives coffee yeah but I don't know I
[ __ ] with celery Gary would [ __ ] you up
oh it still doesn't I had dairy earlier
so enjoy that who's gonna start smelling
like a hellhole real soon the thing is
nothing new so let me ask you this
though what just to make fun of you a
little bit so you grew up around strong
women and then when you decide for me
you said [ __ ] that I'm gonna be
different no yeah maybe I don't know I
got comfortable and like not only that I
was just tired and I was like still
stupid I'm still stupid I learned from
it I went on to work on TV again for a
little bit to get my [ __ ] together and
you couldn't have brought that same
experience to Davis so comedy well I had
to go back into I hadn't done TV and
like [ __ ] like that and so long that's
why I knew you were on my film set and
you were perfectly fine that oh and you
had a babysit me he I lived in this room
because he never could be on time and
it's to ensure that he would be on set
on time and I also paid her so damn
[ __ ] straight you did it was great
cuz the film didn't [ __ ] pay you know
yeah good times though I mean you
punched a wall oh ok let's give up let's
give a little context here so number one
you know I make a lot of jokes like
number one like I'm a [ __ ] which I am
I'm a huge [ __ ] however when I was
younger I used to have a very bad temper
not so much anymore not as bad as it
used to be
unless triggered to the point where like
it's like you really have to you really
have to treat me like [ __ ] to get me mad
like most of the time I say 99% of the
time I
can joke about something laugh about it
turn it into a funny story rant about it
later and I'm pretty damn good but we
won't name the person who pissed me off
on set but somebody pissed me off on set
really really [ __ ] bad and mind you
it was to a point of it was a level of
disrespect that I don't think anybody
should be spoken to that way it was a
waste of your time it was a waste of my
time there was a buildup of like not
considering your time not considering my
time and you know partially cuz my film
too so it didn't really make sense and
you know because I'm I'm not passive but
I tried to be understanding about other
people's situation but it got to a point
where you know I'm looking over at the
schedule or I'm like no this is actually
done really poorly and so mind you I'm
doing my channel I'm doing a whole I
started up a couple of businesses at
that point and I'm doing the film at the
same time and so literally the amount of
time that I was sleeping was very very
[ __ ] minimal and the majority that
sleep that I got was actually onset when
I was taking naps so it got to a point
where I was showing up on set like five
to six times and I just wasn't doing
anything and during that time I could be
working on my other businesses and they
didn't need me on set and they knew it
but they just never would never tell me
well just in case they're like well
something switches up the thing is we
were getting so ahead of schedule they
started adding things and it made my job
difficult as well because it wasn't just
you we had so many other elements of the
film that I would have to call them
last-minute hey can you actually come in
today yeah and that's a little how it
runs normally and so that's kind of it's
the whole situation was not it was not
it was just very stressful you know it
was a super low budget film and once
again I'm not talking about these gripes
as if you know somebody should feel
sorry for us we knew what we were in for
but there were definitely certain things
that just wasn't being considered just
because there's a lot of situations and
basically somebody says something mian
said that really just just got me to a
point where number one I don't like
being like that I don't like getting
angry like for real for real
and so I got [ __ ] mad and I literally
just saw red I grabbed his [ __ ] chair
and I was I was thinking about grabbing
this chair and [ __ ] smashing it over
this fools head but instead you punched
the chair first yeah but but nobody has
seen you that angry but me and so I just
sat there everyone was freaked out that
you need
him let it out if somebody's gonna get
punched they just gotta let me get angry
so I literally just broke this [ __ ]
chair smash this table walked over to a
[ __ ] wall and then I just started
pounding my fist into it until I
couldn't feel my fist but you also you
were about to punch that fence but then
I saw you register it wasn't ours so
then you were like I'm gonna punch a
brick wall I'll consider I had even when
I'm angry that was like a loose tooth
fence at his house and I found the punch
it but I'm like this is not my house so
I hit the wall instead I saw the thought
process happen as well and then that we
had someone tried to go up to her and I
literally stopped him I said you need to
stay away from him or he will kill you
like just let him express everything and
then he'll sit down and be calm yeah so
essentially what happened was at that
point like the person that made me upset
was like the reason why it kind of
tipped me over was because that person
would be very disrespectful towards me
and he just goes - well that's [ __ ]
show business and then I was I didn't
what'd you just say to me bro you know
and it just it was it was I don't like
being demeaned you know it just it
didn't it did not it was the last thing
I [ __ ] needed especially on my own
set it was also your one day off like we
shot six days a week and we only had one
day off technically and that was like
one of your only days off for me to
sleep just sleep mind you I mean every
part of the film yeah and then so like
when they were like oh can you call and
I had already been on set and it was a
last-minute thing and they're like can
you call David and tell him to be on set
and I remember saying are you guys sure
you're gonna use him this is not okay
you've already called him like four
different times the other day like last
week like he's gonna be pissed and
they're like no we're gonna use him blah
blah blah
and then the timing he just ended up
sitting there for like seven hours doing
absolutely [ __ ] nothing
and you know for most sets to like honor
that'll happen but you're getting paid
for it you know and I know this is my
film and stuff but at the same time it
was big damn well knew they didn't need
me know it was also at a point where we
were exhausted it was a lot happening
and no sleeping for a [ __ ] month is
kind of tiring you know and then it just
it just got really bad and you know like
I don't think I handled the situation
maybe as well as I would if I was well
rested but I basically took the dude
aside and I said you know you need to
apologize and if you ever talk to me
like that again I'm just gonna [ __ ] you
up
you could just handle it you know and
like who does that sound like a David so
thing like I would never say that to
somebody you know so it was just like it
was just like this very weird situation
I don't really like it but it is what it
is David shows a nice guy tell you piss
him off which is very hard to do it's
very very hard to do and I'm not saying
that I like when this happens I'm like
i'ma beat everybody up there's like a
80% chance I'm gonna get my ass kicked
however I'm willing to take that [ __ ]
risk yeah yeah I mean that one was a it
was I was laughing and that whole thing
happened because like these guys didn't
understand I don't think you gonna piss
him off well they just kept poking me
you know and it's like this is not and
then when it finally happened everyone
was so scared I was laughing because I'm
like he's about to swell up and he's
gonna [ __ ] be so sorry everybody was
nice so nice after they were fear deal
oh and they were and they were better at
scheduling everybody else's [ __ ] too cuz
you know I had a conversation that you
weren't you weren't the only person that
complained about it yeah so but it
shouldn't have gotten to the point where
I flip out and tell people like you'll
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] right and then now
people are there scheduling it better
it's like you go come on yeah but you
know you live in your learn I guess is
what it is well what did you learn today
I learned that I make bad choices and I
need to reevaluate how I go about it
good would you learn today I learned
that you're still stupid and yeah Here I
am
piece of [ __ ] no anyways guys that
concludes this episode of genius brain
podcast everybody and I would like to
say hello hello hello and thank you for
watching we're in like at above a
thousand five star ratings are you
taking a photo go ahead they're about
we're above like a thousand star ratings
on iTunes continue to do that thank you
very much as you can see this podcast
has been getting sponsorships thanks to
your guys's support so now I officially
stopped sucking dick for money so thank
you for that on my lips are getting
chapped anyways I'm not gonna deny that
anyways
Spotify cash box we're talking about
iTunes podcast any kind of audio
platform genius brain podcast is on
there
check us out thank you once again Thank
You Danielle for continually making
mistakes that we could hear about on
this pot
because I like this sure I'll be back
with more at mistakes yeah we'll see
what other men you're gonna get to cheat
on you anyways whoa again I was the
other girl my [ __ ] bad anyways guys
we'll see you next time peace oh where
can they find you a few if you want them
to find you um Instagram and Twitter are
the same Danielle s Lee Danielle s Lee
go on there and harass her please please
not harass me maybe sometimes you'll see
him really I just post stupid stuff and
photos and my friends and then watch her
stupid stories the one that she denies
that she did it does and it's gonna be
true listen her half moon that was like
five years ago stop bringing that up
that was like five days ago
anyways guys we'll see you next time bye